i think it's important to clear up this
question of our comparative economic
performance actually
so we calculate gdp in a different way
to
pretty much every other country
something that the office for national
statistics and the bank of england
have pointed out now if you if you
correct for that difference or look at
it in a more comparable way nominal gdp
what you find is
our performance is actually very much in
line with all our international kids
well actually it's a little bit better
than places like canada italy spain and
germany when i when i looked at it
but it's definitely you know in line to
slightly better and actually our
employment performance if you look at
unemployment or the change in employment
is again better than most of our
international peers so
but is there much to celebrate in you
know 2020s numbers when you look at them
no what what the numbers show is that
our economy suffered a significant shock
last year and whilst there was some
resilience
in winter what's clear is that right now
many families
many businesses are experiencing
hardship and that's why it's right that
we've provided
the comprehensive support that we have
through our plan for jobs
and we'll be setting up the next stage
of that at budget in early march
and when you look back at the kind of
interventions you made last year you
know is there anything that you think
well we could have done it a little bit
differently to have more of an impact to
get the economy going a bit more
well i think you could always
second-guess yourself but i think it's
important that we
respond to the situation as we find it
of course we're making decisions
in the face of uncertainty but i think
you know i think but you know what i
mean
any regret regrets that that might feed
into your decision-making now that
you're coming out towards
i think i think the key thing is to make
sure that we have a sense of priorities
and
my priority has always been to try and
protect as many people's jobs
as possible that was the priority at the
start it remains my priority now and i
think that is the right priority to have
as we think about the next phase
of of the pandemic and how our economy
recovers through it
and you think that you've got that
balance right do you well i mean people
leave that for other people to judge but
with interventions like the furlough
scheme
you know which we were able to put
together a short period of time
and our support for those who are
self-employed all of that has helped
protect millions of people's jobs and we
know from the data
that that has helped unemployment you
know whilst it is obviously rising and
many people have lost their jobs
is lower than many people forecast in
part because of the interventions that
we've put in place
i think most people have acknowledged
that that support has
lowered unemployment relative to what it
otherwise would have been limited the
number of business failures
you know but of course many people are
suffering hardship haven't lost sight of
that and we will keep providing that
support
and and looking you know the states of
economy a lot of businesses a lot of
households are just wondering
you know is life ever going to return
to normal so what's your message to them
of course understands people's
anxiety and frustration about everything
but i think what
people would want is for this to
hopefully be the last knock down
and we want to make it feel good about
that i think what i do feel very good
about is the vaccine roll out and i pay
enormous tribute to everyone who's
been involved with that huge national
effort and that gives us reasons for
cautious optimism
so what the prime minister and i are now
doing and i think what people want us to
do is
is to be careful and cautious look at
all the data that we're getting in
base our decisions on that evidence and
the prime minister will set out that
road map
of the week of february the 22nd but do
you understand that the frustration i
think that a lot of businesses and
households are failing because you know
they want to
plan they want to know what to do with
their lives and at the moment a lot of
people just feel like they're in limbo
yeah i
absolutely understand that frustration
it is a time of uncertainty but what i
would tell people is certainly on the
economic side
you know our support runs all the way
through to spring furlough for example
to the end of april
and we'll have a budget early in march
to set out the next phase of economic
support
to provide people with that reassurance
and certainty and that will follow
from the prime minister's roadmap the
week before and i know that you're not
going to give away the details of what's
in that budget but can you just give us
a sense of
you know what the broads theme is going
to be well
as as we've been discussing my priority
throughout this crisis has always been
to try and protect as many people's jobs
as possible through this very difficult
period that will remain my overriding
economic
priority it's not about kind of raising
taxes it's not about trying to balance
the books right now well i think
public finances are important and we've
only been able to provide the support
that we have
because of a strong economy and strong
public finances coming into this
and i want to make sure that whenever
the next
shock hits the country that we can also
respond in the same way
that will require our public finances to
be put back in a strong and sustainable
position and i've said i will always be
honest
and upfront with people about what
exactly that means